[Music]
[Applause]
uh let's bring in Marcus Spears the big
swagu ESPN NFL analyst and uh you can
see him on NFL live at four Eastern
every weekday on the mothership good to
have you back Marcus could Russell
Wilson have shaken off his coach when
Nathaniel Hackett said we're going to go
for the field goal could Russ have said
no I want to go for it
BP yeah man good to see you uh yeah I
think he's built the cafe to be able to
do that
um especially understanding that moment
like we can't say in one breath that
Russell Wilson is one of the better
fourth quarter quarterbacks in the
league over over the last 10 years eight
years and then also him not have he just
got by the way BP he just got a quarter
of a billion dollars in a contract so
I'm sure Russell Wilson has more weight
in the Denver franchise than his head
coach at the moment right
um I think he could have um and look I'm
not gonna blame Russell Wilson uh for
not doing it obviously you got a head
coach and it's a title for a reason but
there's also like it is some blame to go
around like what other coach on the
coaching staff didn't run over and say
hey hey Nathaniel like let's take a time
out and at least think about what we're
going to do or let's take a time out
let's keep the field goal if we miss it
we still may have time to get the ball
back because we'll have two timeouts
left
um it was just it was a massive failure
and obviously we gonna give the brunt of
it to the head coach because ultimately
he has to make that decision and he's
the offensive mind but I think Russ had
enough cachet and he has enough stock in
the NFL in his career and enough success
to be like man I'm calling time out you
just be mad at me uh Tuesday and
Thursday and the rest of the week but
I'm gonna try to give us the best chance
to win and maybe you aren't ready for
this moment in your first NFL game coach
I just didn't know why you don't take a
time out to at least discuss it do we
have a play that we really like has this
worked and and then you can run the
clock after that if you want to but at
least get down to a 40-yard field goal
not 64 on the road that's what I don't
understand BP
field goals over 60 yards since the
1960s you know how many have been made
it they're two of 41.
like two of 41. that that is in what
world and I get it that we got different
type of kickers they got bigger legs we
understand that guys can kick for
distance we've seen it but those odds as
opposed to a fourth and five with a
quarterback that has done this
over 50 times since we've watched him
play it was mind-boggling man and and
look everybody reaction was Peyton's
reaction yeah like all time out yeah
like just settle yourself down not to
mention there was the other thing that
Peyton and Eli brought up and that was
they were getting out of the huddle with
like 11 seconds to go and the whole
thing with the quarterback nowadays is I
get to sort of survey the landscape well
I can survey with 16 or 17 or 15 seconds
11 we start to get into uh oh and that's
I didn't understand that you know coming
from we're not being harsh we're not
being harsh by this DPS because look
every time I'm in the NFL when you make
a statement like we have overreaction
week one no we're reacting to week one
we'll react to week two when it happens
we'll react to the next good thing we'll
react to the next bad thing and then
that'll be a culmination the things that
happen throughout the season and that'll
tell us where these teams are and why
they are where they are but this is not
an overreaction to week one you're an
NFL head coach you've been given that
title you've been you've seen enough
games you come from a family of coaches
where they've been in these critical
situations where you have to make a
decision and I'm not going to give
Nathaniel a Hackett a pass because it's
his first game coaching
DP I could everybody they got Peewee
coaches that would have called time out
in that situation yeah they got guys you
don't have to like there is no rocket
science element there is no other thing
that we can talk about well maybe he was
thinking this or maybe he was thinking
that if he was thinking that I'm going
to bleed the clock to try to kick a
64-yard field goal that's horrible
coaching is all it is that's the answer
if I had Justin Tucker I'm fine with it
but and if I'm in Denver Then I then I
could at least go okay I understand this
it's a home field it's a elevation I'm a
little bit better not on the road trying
to kick that field goal when I this is
why I traded for Russell Wilson because
if I had if I had Drew lock then I do
kick the field goal I got Russell Wilson
on Fourth and five we're talking to the
big swagoo Marcus Spears okay
I don't know how well you know Jerry
Jones but you were a cowboy at once I'm
wondering
can Jerry Stan Pat with Cooper rush and
not be tempted to go after Jimmy
Garoppolo
if if you're trying to win if you
believe that you can win you don't stand
Pat with Cooper Rush like but but then
there's an underlying issue
all off season
if you're a Super Bowl let's put this in
context I was going to get up this
morning talking about this and I'm so
frustrated with the Cowboys because I
spent all off season saying why is
nothing happening the roster honestly DP
the roster wasn't good enough to win a
championship before all of this happened
it wasn't and and I know people want to
be optimistic about their teams and you
know we talk about like the Jets had a
good draft and the lions or a team
that's on the scent realistically they
not winning the Super Bowl they're not
good enough to win one they don't have
the roster yet to win one Dallas didn't
have the roster before Dak Prescott got
hurt so you now go into crisis
management you go into desperation and
now you're in a position where you got
to go with Cooper Rush with a team that
doesn't have the requisite weapons at
wide receiver uh offensive line that's
young that that is the reason that your
quarterback has to have thumb surgery
giving up two pressures back to back to
Shaquille Barrett which in turn is why
Dak Prescott thumb is broken like I hate
to sound so harsh on Tyler Smith but
that's the reality of it that's football
good offensive lineman good tackles give
up sacks sometimes their quarterbacks
get hurt but ultimately that's that's
the result of that so now
you got Cooper Rush and everybody's
talking about this favorable schedule I
want people to acknowledge that the
Dallas Cowboys roster is not good
it's not good it wasn't and in context
what are we talking about are we talking
about this team being a wild card are we
talking about them winning nine or ten
games to appease people to make them
think that going into 23-24 season we
can make a few moves and be a better
team they stood Pat and did nothing but
going back to my point of what I was
talking about oh get up this morning DP
let's go through the list
of teams that's trying to win a Super
Bowl
the Los Angeles Ram I mean the Los
Angeles Chargers went out and got Khalil
Mack and JC Jackson They fortified a run
defense getting Sebastian Joseph Day
from the Los Angeles Rams because on the
other side of the ball they had Justin
Herbert Keenan Allen and Mike Williams
and they said to themselves as a front
office we can win a championship let's
go do what it takes to win a
championship Devonte Adams wanted to go
back and play with Derek Hall fine but
the Las Vegas Raiders had to go get
Devante Adams they had to do it because
they want to win a championship
the Buffalo Bills were uh 13 seconds
away from going to the AFC Championship
game
they said we aren't good enough we
didn't close on Patrick Mahomes in the
last 13 seconds let's go get Von Miller
and let's try to win a championship the
Tampa Bay Buccaneers for the last three
years or two years however long time
it's been there has made every roster
decision to win a Super Bowl they went
and got Antonio Brown with nobody in the
lead thought he would come back after
the Raiders debacle this year they go
get Julio Jones and everybody Julio was
he oh he Julio looked great to me
because what the Tampa Bay Buccaneers
are thinking is if I could put Julio
across from Mike Evans when Chris Godwin
in the middle I can have something
without having to ask Julio to catch 100
Balls on the season okay the Los Angeles
Rams for the last four to five years
have mortgaged their future to win a
Super Bowl guess what DP we do not care
about that because they are the reigning
defending Super Bowl champions they
bought themselves they've answered the
question that every fan is gonna have
maybe when the time comes that they're
not doing well they're gonna say well we
exhausted it all and we won the Super
Bowl all right now we in rebuild mode
the Dallas Cowboys stood Pat and did
nothing oh by the way in their division
BP
the Philadelphia Eagles winning Sam
Bradberry because they needed a better
secondary
they also went and signed AJ Brown
and and and Jerry Jones and Stephen
Jones
say it verbalem we like our guys
and they scored they didn't they not
only only scored three points they
didn't get in the red zone
in the game against sample but hey they
want to win Super Bowls it's the Dallas
Cowboys we gonna run this thing through
Zeke Elliott DP if you were going to win
a championship running the football
um I'm so frustrated they're slipping my
run Derrick Henry would have three
the Tennessee Titans would have three
Super Bowls if you could run your way to
one you know what happened when the
Tennessee Titans went and took a 25 uh
took a lead against the uh Kansas City
Chiefs a few years back in the playoffs
the Kansas City Chiefs had Patrick
Mahomes
and they had a they had weapons like
Travis Kelsey and Tyreek Hill oh I
didn't mention that the Miami Dolphins
signed Tyreek hill with a quarterback
that ain't as good as Dak Prescott you
know why because they trying to win a
championship but I digress I'm sorry
brother I just had to get that off
are you in a Supply Closet at ESPN
I'm actually in the makeup room the one
that's not occupied
so so you're I need to be in the closet
praying
[Music]
I need that I need a prayer closet is
what I need do you ever do you want to
hit ever want to hit somebody because
you I mean you spent more than half your
life hitting people you don't get to
anymore
not not not as much as I used to but
when I see things transpiring football
games I want to hit people but now it's
illegal DP so I have to I have to
channel that energy towards doing what
we're doing right now and random raving
about the dumb things that happen but
would you like to do what Leonard
fournette did to Micah Parsons yes
absolutely it's nothing better there's
nothing better to make another man know
that you were there okay then you're DP
you remember like there was this company
or whatever wish you were here or
something like that sometimes you have
that feeling as a former football player
where you just want to make people know
that yeah I used to do this I used to
lock offensive lineman out and drag them
to their knees and hit running backs and
let them know that I was here yeah I
missed that man I just have nobody here
to do that against anymore if orlovsky
walks in you wouldn't you love to pop
him just once yeah but but that you know
it's not it's not that exciting because
he was an easy sack when he was playing
so it ain't it ain't that exciting but I
do have times where I want to hit it
uh I'm trying to think if Damien Woody
came in
yeah
I don't want to get witty because both
of us are both of our knees would fall
out later
uh good to talk to you again as always
thanks for uh spending some time with us
and uh we'll be watching this afternoon
NFL live at four Eastern thank you my
brother and I have to acknowledge that
LSU helmet in the back I love it keep it
up all right Marcus Marcus Spears
uh NFL live at four Eastern